hey guys Greg knuckles here with string
theory calm back with the third
installment of this semi daily Q&A the
question today is how dangerous is
lifting weights
what are your injury risks compared to
other sports and also what's the what's
the long-term injury risk what are what
are the chances that you know you'll
wind up broken down at the end of it so
to address the first question this is
something that's been studied a pretty
fair amount a lot of research
how about quantifying risk in a given
sport is number of injuries per thousand
hours they've looked at this for
powerlifting bodybuilding weightlifting
strongman and most of the studies tend
to cluster around somewhere between one
and five injuries per thousand hours or
so just to put that in context that is a
pretty similar injury rate to triathlon
training and a little bit lower than
training for distance running and quite
a bit lower than most team sports so
your odds of your odds of suffering an
acute injury in the gym compared to
other sports or is pretty low that
doesn't mean that it's not going to
happen but you know basically you have
the same risk of getting hurt lifting
weights as you would from a lower risk
of getting heart lifting weights than
you would from playing most sports out
there so you know not saying it's zero
risk but compared to most other things
most other athletic things that people
do it is a pretty safe endeavor but then
people are concerned that you know maybe
the acute injury risk isn't all that
high but it's going to mess you up in
the long term it increases your chronic
injury risk to the best of my knowledge
this has only been studied once an older
study by a researcher named
it's Gerald and basically what he did is
just compared signs of joint
degeneration in a population of lifters
to an age matched population of people
in the general population if I'm
remembering correctly the lifters had
been training on average a little bit
over 12 years and were on average and
their mid-30s or so I will post the
study below then and didn't refresh the
details before I started recording but
something like that and they they were
all high level competitors so you know
these weren't just schlubs you know
benching 135 or whatever like these were
guys who were really really good power
lifters and weight lifters and they
found that rates of joint degeneration
you know onset of osteoarthritis stuff
like that was basically the same between
the lifters and people in the general
population you know there are a lot of
lifters who after putting in a lot of
time under the bar I do start to get
kind of broke down a little bit but
there are also a lot of people who don't
lift who just start to get broken down
over time a lot of that just seems to be
inherent in the aging process so it
doesn't it doesn't necessarily seem like
lifting increases your risk of that but
it doesn't decrease it either so in the
short term it does seem that lifting is
a pretty safe endeavor compared to most
other sports and that long term it
doesn't increase your risk of your
joints breaking down over time now one
thing I will mention about that study by
Fitzgerald is since these were high
level lifters there may be some
survivorship bias there it could be that
you know other people who hint have been
able to stick with it as long did break
down quicker that is that is entirely
possible just to raise raise a complaint
that I've heard about that study before
but right now there's there's really no
evidence to speak to that one way or
another so based on the available
evidence
right now all we can say is that you
know justjust I guess to repeat myself
lifting is is pretty safe in terms of
acute injury risk just as safe or safer
than most other sports out there and as
far as we can tell it doesn't increase
long-term risk of joint degeneration now
just to get into this a little bit more
in terms of sports that do seem to be
the safest in terms of injury risk
bodybuilding in terms of lifting related
sport seems to be about the safest
strongman seems to be the most risky and
powerlifting weightlifting and CrossFit
are all three somewhere in the middle in
terms of injury risk alright guys so
that is the video if you liked it please
like and subscribe and if you have a
question you want answered ask it in the
comments below and if it's my favorite I
will answer it in tomorrow's video till
then guys see you later